[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me live from the
Algonquin Commons theater
my name is Joshua fields Melbourne and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and we are live in
Ottawa
alright welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less we
are going to answer some questions we
have a microphone right around here
somewhere and then there's one in the
balcony up there as well
look at those spotlights you just came
on and have illuminated the place to
answer your to actually to ask your
questions if you have if you have some
answers that'd be great too because we
came with about 17 different answers and
one of them will be applied to your
question this evening
howdy what's your name Roxanne get me
any Roxanne I'm from Ottawa here
thanks for coming thank you for coming
you're welcome my question for you is
where do you see yourselves in five
years of the impact that you've made in
the world what do you want the world to
look like imagine your life five years
from that's right you know I I don't
typically think in those terms and I'll
tell you why I don't there's a specific
reason I tend to look one year down the
line in most cases in fact Ryan and I
tend to plan a year in advance you know
we planned this tour it's a year-long
tour it's I mean we only go out for like
four cities at a time and then we'll go
back home but everything we do for a
year will then serve whatever that main
objective for the year is that main
project that we're working on it main
creative endeavor that that we are
embarking on and so the reason I don't
look at five years though is because if
I were to go back five years ago and and
and had told my 31 year old self if I
would have told him here the here's
everything that's gonna happen in the
next five years you're going to publish
this book you're going to go on 100 City
tour in 2014 you're gonna build
elementary schools in Laos or fund high
schools in Kenya or you're going to help
the folks from the Orlando Paul's
nightclub shooting if you would have
gotten given me this whole list of here
are the things you need to focus on for
the next five years I probably just
throw my hands up and said that's way
too overwhelming
that's way too much stuff for me to try
to accomplish over the course of these
five years
and instead I find it's one of these
baby steps where it's sort of like a
horizon sometimes that if you if you are
driving somewhere where it's really flat
like Saskatchewan if you ever made that
drive to like Edmonton it seems like a
mirage by the way all of a sudden
there's just the city there and I'm like
oh my god I hope there's a Tim Horton's
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah so so I I feel that way like
there's always gonna be a horizon and
once I get that horizon for me tends to
be about one year and then once I get to
that horizon it's not like I got there
and I'm done there's just a new horizon
now and so I keep traveling toward that
horizon so instead the important thing
for me is to figure out what is the
right direction and let's travel in that
direction I will tell you this I am
encouraged by the different types of
people who are coming to our events we
have a lot of kids high school kids
college kids or show up to the events
now after the documentary came out and I
guess we could probably announce this
here now we're moving somewhere new and
we're not announcing it publicly but
it's just between us right oh yeah we
were moving to Ottawa we are we're going
to the place where people go to tell
stories and you we were able to make a
big impact with this documentary you put
out we want to do a lot more video work
and so actually in two days I'm moving
to Los Angeles California
we could try to alternate here do we
have another question up top or no oh
yes we do wait howdy can I give an
answer nope yep maybe no I was just the
only thing I say is to looking out from
five years from now I actually used to
you know think five years ago when we
started this I'm like man like how how
is this going to have an effect and what
kind of impact are we gonna have and how
are we gonna put our dent in the
universe and what I'll say is that what
I thought five years ago none of it has
come to fruition it has been on because
of that short term focus that Josh was
just talking about and really you know
at the end of the day I was I was raised
Jehovah's Witness like a very strict
Christian religion and you know there's
a lot of rules that come along with that
and when I've learned up to this point
in my life is that you know for me I'm
not going to you know prescribe to any
one religion or any any whatever I am
going to try to be like the best person
I can be and put as much as I can out
there with no expectations
and I think it's important to look
long-term there's no doubt about that
but when I when I think about how I used
to get caught up in the how am I gonna
how am I gonna put my dent in the
universe and how many lives am I gonna
be able to to help and Who am I gonna
help you know change their their paths
and so forth and so on when I really
think about that that's kind of like the
ego taken over so now it's it's not it's
not about like I'm so happy y'all are
here like I am so happy but thank you at
the end of the day they're like Josh and
I we don't expect this and this isn't
what we're going for this is what is
happening and it is as a result as Josh
and I living meaningful lives sharing
our story and in philosophy and this is
a beautiful beautiful beautiful accident
and we will continue to do this as long
as we can but you know five years from
now I'll still be living a meaningful
life I know that we'll go up top here
howdy what's your name that's where are
you from I'm from welcome I was just
wondering if any of the history or the
theory behind what minimalism is or any
of that stuff is of interest or is it
sort of you came across it you used it
it worked and then you moved forward
with it yeah I'm I am it depends what
you mean by history as well so history
of the term minimalism which was sort of
started in 1960s as a movement in terms
of art and architecture and eventually
in the 80s with literature with people
like Lorrie Moore or Bret Easton Ellis
Jay McInerney but in terms of minimalism
or simplicity as a life style which in
the 60s was just called voluntary
simplicity that interests me but going
back even farther than that you can look
at pretty much every major world
religion and there are elements of
living more intentionally being more
deliberate contributing beyond yourself
getting rid of the excess simplifying
and then even back to the Stoics they
would often talk about dealing with with
distractions
and temporary deprivation and doing
stoical experiments and even if you go
way back to the ascetics they believed
and I don't believe in this but they
sort of believed in perpetual suffering
was the way to to bring us contentment
we don't have to start doing that right
no we don't yeah and also Fight Club oh
man um yeah I I I kind of like
minimalism art and I've been getting
into some music a little bit like I love
me some Einstein on the beach
but you know at the end of the day I had
no idea what minimalism was before I had
that conversation with Josh and when I
heard about it it was this very common
sense thing it was like this oh yeah if
I don't have this huge mortgage hanging
over my head if I'm not buying a new car
every two years then maybe I won't have
to work 60 70 80 hours a week yeah that
makes sense so for me when I found out
about minimalism it was really about
reclaiming my time paying off as much
debt as I could I mean really I just
wanted to be a barista I was like man if
I could find a way to live off a you
know 20 to 24 thousand dollars a year
which is very doable in Dayton Ohio and
be a barista and work part-time I would
be able to reclaim my time to at least
allow myself to refocus on the path that
I did want to go down but I certainly
have respect for all of the other
avenues of minimalism in fact if you
look it up in the dictionary it's
there's nothing about life style in
there it's all about art architecture
which I love but but yeah for me it was
it was the lifestyle that I first
discovered it thank you
thank you yeah before before we move on
for folks who are listening to this at
home if you have a comment or tip for
anyone who asks those two questions a
day you can you can leave us a voicemail
message 4 zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine or from your phone you
can send a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists calm I can tell you
it's probably my favorite segment of the
entire show is at the very end when we
have voicemail callers and and they will
leave these tips because one of the
reasons Ryan and I go out on the road is
to listen and and to hear other people's
perspectives because we certainly don't
have all the answers and I have in fact
we often have conflicting answers and I
think that's okay it allows me to either
change my mind or strengthen my point of
view and quite often people call in they
have phenomenal tips for people are
asking questions they have tips
correcting us when we are wrong or they
just have good resources to pass on to
our audience so always at the end of the
episode we you should play a handful of
handful of messages Ryan do you know
what time it is
OMM it is time for our hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning around where
usually we answer questions from social
media but that would be weird since you
guys are here if you all got your phones
out right now all just started tweeting
at us then we have failed miserably but
we we are for the folks listens at home
we're on Twitter and Instagram and
Facebook at the minimalists and we what
we're gonna do
we usually have like a week to craft a
beautiful pithy shareable minimal Maxim
for you that we can give to you right
now but we have just a few seconds so
we'll do is we'll ramble a little bit
and then we'll come up with a pithy
answer that one of you can tweet at some
point we also put all the links to all
these in the show notes and also Jessica
puts these on are we decided a little
like side website called minimal Maxim's
it has like hundreds or maybe even
thousands of our quotes at this point
what's your name thanks for coming
tonight thanks for being here and my
question like I was raised as a
minimalist by my dad at least in terms
of material possession so my question is
more about finances and college debt and
I know you guys say like no good debt
like no debt is good debt however to
raise say $40,000 for
that's ten thousand a year in high
school every year and right now I'm on
the path of doing it but that that's a
lot of 16-hour days on the weekend
that's a lot of like 60 hour weeks
during the summer and wouldn't you think
that taking on a bit of student debt and
then repaying it would be like a more
effective use of your time no that's a
really pithy answer I I will ramble a
little bit but but the here's what all
so what are you going to college for
well I'm still in high school but I'm
sorry what do you want to go to college
for probably dental hygiene program and
that's important to go to college for
that because I don't let DIY would you
like to practice on Ryan's teeth right
now
no I so that's important and I think
it's first important to delineate if
we're going to go to off to university
is this necessary or oh here's my pithy
answer for you but it has little to do
with your question my pithy answer is
don't confuse schooling with education I
I don't have a college degree of any
sort and somehow I still had student
loan debt
yeah and so so I'll tell you I'll tell
you this I what I was going to college
for why I started taking some class for
was like business management but I
learned that I was already knew the
stuff they were teaching because I had
gone through it in the real world first
you know I started managing some stores
and then some employees and I I
understood the fundamentals of it I
stumbled my way through it and and that
was important so for folks who listen to
this who are considering should I go to
college or shouldn't I go to college the
answer is yeah maybe it really depends
on on the right you want to go but there
are other ways to get a great education
it can be internships it can be trade
schools it can be starting your own
business I mean for me being an
entrepreneur is one of the the most
difficult things but also one of the
most educational things that I can do
for myself that said yes you need some
money in order to be able to go to
university and there are a couple ways
you can do it but the first thing I
would I would ask you is is there a
dental hygienist who made it through
college anywhere in Canada who left
college with zero student loan debt if
so if I were you instead of getting into
debt I would find some money to pay that
person to sit down and talk to them and
figure out what their template was how
the heck did you get through you four
years of university completely debt free
because that yeah we're asking you at
age eighteen when you turn eighteen to
sign up for debt that we wouldn't give
to any other eighteen year old for any
other reason other than you would never
just go to a an 18 year old say here's
$40,000 figure it out and so III I
wouldn't encourage you to do that as
well by the way your prefrontal cortex
doesn't fully develop until you're 25
right but like in terms of like you can
save ten thousand a year every year in
high school and then you can go to
college debt-free but it's just you're
then working a job where you make after
taxes like nine dollars an hour and so
your time doesn't go as far as it would
if you took on student loans is what I
mean is what I mean yeah I I totally see
where you're coming from
first off I just want to say that having
like someone in high school at one of
our events it's like the biggest comment
on the world so
thank you for the support and I'm so
glad that you're here
[Applause]
yeah that is awesome I gotta tell you
that is the best use of a fake ID oh my
god that's awesome that's great man I
had a real pithy answer but I'm like
totally blanking now I think my pithy
answer would be this and I want to
expound a little bit graduating college
with zero debt it's gonna feel so much
better than graduating college with a
lot of debt and I mean that's obviously
true but what I'll say is like right now
you are it's it's it's important to put
those those hours in and here's why it's
because living at that free life Josh
and I have never said being debt-free is
easy in fact it's really really hard and
I even talked about that in the
beginning of the talk where I say hey
this is not a perfect life and it's
definitely not an easy life but it's a
simple one and we often confuse simple
with easy and simple is not easy going
with the flow getting into debt doing
what the norm is that's easy I mean it
blows my mind I don't know how it is in
Canada I don't know how much debt they
allow an eighteen year old to take on
out of college but in the United States
you can get six figures worth of debt
you can't go buy a drink but you can you
can get into six figures worth it that
it's insane and it's really nice that we
have all this freedom but I'm totally
gonna rip this off from spider-man but
with that freedom
comes great responsibility and you're
being really responsible right now and
you are no get clapper a she's been
responsible you know when I first
discovered minimalism I didn't just quit
my job and start a blog it's like the
worst advice anyone could give you it
took me another year and a half to two
years to really really work a plan that
I had made and I still was working 60 70
80 hours a week I was going to school at
the time and I was writing for the blog
so you know minimalism doesn't help you
just drop all responsibilities and you
know give you the ability to go live on
the beach right away but if you
certainly work hard you can get to you
know whatever you took through dental
hygiene school debt-free and you know
you are you're so young like you've got
the energy now to work you don't want to
wait till you're like you know 22 you'll
still have energy then but you know I
wish I wish that I had your mindset when
I was in high school like if I could
have saved 10 grand I was like stressing
out how I'm gonna buy an $80.00
skateboard in high school let alone like
saving 10,000 bucks to go to college I
mean college was out of the question
because I mean my parents didn't support
that I didn't start college so I was in
the corporate world but but what what
I'll say is keep doing what you're doing
I know it's hard now but I promise you
if you put the work in now you're gonna
be so much happier when you get to
college thank you
we'll go back up top here howdy what's
your name hello my name is Joanne I'm
originally from New Brunswick but I've
been living in Ottawa for about 10 years
now thank you for being here in our
lovely capital city thank you I have two
questions the first one is Oh actually
before I said I start I got rid of one
thing today I'm doing your Facebook
challenge so I got day one I got rid of
one thing 30-day minimalism game for
those of you uninformed
congratula would you get rid of I'm just
curious I got rid of a computer desk
that was in a room that was empty that
was not useful at all awesome that's um
two questions the first one is tricks
and chips when we have trouble getting
rid of something in terms something
that's not for me for example it's a lot
of oh well my mother gave this to me
maybe one day I'll want to give it to my
daughter future daughter that they don't
even have by the way or you know this
picture really means a lot to me I'd
like to share it with someone or movie
maybe I want to keep it for it to
remember so that's my first question my
second question is how to instill this
in children so how do you educate
children about minimalism and and what
we can do to to educate them so that
they have that from a very young age but
you take the first one and all I'll take
the kids question sure um sentimental
stuff is definitely the hardest things
to let go I mean for me that was the
hardest thing for me to like let go
after the packing party I was putting
stuff and you know donate so recycling
and I came across a shoebox with like
all these letters that my mom had
written me in high school and like at
the time those letters meant so much to
me in high school and the thought of
like throwing those letters away it was
like I just didn't feel good so I was
like no no no dude you're your
minimalist now man you gotta like throw
this away and I couldn't like quite let
go of the whole shoebox of letters and
there was like some pictures of me and
my
prom date and like the shot glass they
gave us for our senior prom gift which
is a horrible gift to give a seat here
kid and what I did is I was like all
right I'm gonna pick a letter I'm gonna
read it and I'm gonna I'm gonna scan it
and I'm gonna throw it away so I just
like picked a random letter and I
remember like the the couple opening
lines like I started to remember the
feeling that that letter gave me when I
was in high school but by the time I got
to the end of of the letter it did not
have that same feeling it's like the
memory of the letter was better than
like experience experiencing it again in
my late 20s and I still scanned it I
threw it in the in the in the trash and
I just thought to myself like all right
like that wasn't too difficult if I for
some reason can't sleep I will you know
get up tomorrow and I will get it out of
the trash I didn't even like remember it
until I went to go take out the trash
the next day or the day after is like
sitting her on top and I was like oh
yeah there's a letter so I I didn't end
up keeping or even like taking pictures
or scanning everything in there there
were just like a few things that that I
had scanned or took a picture of but I
was able to let those those physical
possessions go now it's funny cuz like
I've never well I guess cuz I'm one of
the minimalists like I don't have this
urge to hold on to stuff like to pass on
down to my kids because really like when
I hear people talk about like people
will come to our events there was
there's this one particular time these
these two this couple were was there and
they were talking about how they were
gonna have to deal with like one of
their parents stuff when they pass away
and they hope they held on to so much
stuff and they were like I know my
parents did it out of love and they
wanted to hand down these memories but I
don't want any of it and it's really
stressing me out and you know Josh and I
you know I answered her question and
then the next question there was this
older couple and they were
like we're doing that right now with our
kids and it is so relieving to hear you
say that
so I guess my pet the answer would be if
you don't want to hold on to your [ __ ]
your kids definitely don't want to hold
on to your [ __ ]
[Music]
as far as teaching our kids the thing
that I've learned the most with with
Ella who turned 4 recently she's on
Twitter at Ellis and which for those of
you who went to follow her it's it's our
version of a scrapbook it's just one
tweet at a time
she says the craziest [ __ ]
anyway I've I found out that the my sort
of recipe for teaching her is show tell
show and what I mean by that is I have
to show her something via my actions I
have to tell her about it explain it to
her especially because she's very
inquisitive she's always asking why but
I need to show her again and there needs
to be consistency among the three I
can't say don't use your hand to eat
that broccoli when I just grab the piece
off of her mother's plate and so I I
need to be consistent with my actions my
telling and my actions again and so I
think my my minimal Maxim for you would
be your actions shape your child's
future self
yes
all right real quick before I move on
we've been doing something new
recently Ryan and I well here's here's
the honest truth
you see 5,000 advertisements a day and
we don't want you to see 5001 and so we
refuse to clutter our podcasts with
advertisements and so our our podcast is
a hundred percent listener supported
through a platform called patreon and we
just started doing these weekly they've
been weekly so far this past month
private podcasts and this is sort of a
private podcast in a way so I'd like to
break away for a moment and do something
special answer a few questions just for
everyone here the 600 people in this
room and then for the people who listen
at patreon.com slash the minimalists we
also do live streams and emails and a
bunch of other more intimate stuff and I
feel like I feel like with those
podcasts we can be I don't know a little
bit like I feel like I could sort of let
my hair down or Brian's hair down and so
let's do let's do a product quick like
mini private podcasts for you all and
for patreon I also move back to the
regular podcast real quick Ryan you know
I was thinking as she she was talking
about the yacht and the bonus or the the
private podcast that she was talking
about the the the need and is the thing
you were talking about with expectations
the the need to always respond to check
like that pressure we feel the pressure
like I know I twitch for the device and
that's why I have to remove the the
items from my phone deed the Instagram
or whatever for my phone from time to
time and frequently and I know that that
pressure that I feel it's almost all
internal and and quite often I'm letting
other people's expectations Drive not
just my anxieties but drive my decisions
and I'm becoming reactive
as a result and so I think quite often
what we can do is we can let go of
others expectations and also at the same
time we can lower our expectations that
seems weird and it would be weird for me
to just say lower your expectations and
then goodbye minimalism but I found the
thing that's been so powerful for me is
something I still work on all the time
is lowering my expectations but raising
my standards and what I mean by that is
I know I might not get exactly where I
want to go when I want to get there but
I'm going to do my best to keep going in
the right direction making sure my daily
actions align with my long-term values
and if they do and I've have high enough
standards I will continue to fail but
that's okay because I wasn't expecting
something to be a hundred percent
outstanding all of the time let's move
on real quick to right here right now so
we talked about what's going on in the
lives of the minimalists we're in the
middle of this crazy 40 city tour where
we give a talk about minimalism and then
we record a live podcast and we're in
Canada right now but we're gonna be all
over the states we got 40 cities total
less is now calm we're also going to be
announcing some Australia and New
Zealand dates really soon for those of
you listening at home and hopefully that
goes well a whole bunch of other places
so we're bringing this on the road thank
you for being here tonight a few other
things we have going on I'm teaching my
rap my last writing class of the year so
I've been writing for a really long time
and I kept getting all of these these
questions about writing and I would keep
responding via email until it got to a
point where I couldn't respond anymore
so I started writing class about five
years ago online and it was a four-week
class and it's a big commitment for a
lot of people and I realized it wasn't
ideal for everyone so a couple times a
year I do a two hour how to improve your
writing workshop it's called how to
write better
it's whether you're trying to improve
your business emails or write the your
first novel I've had high school
students and medical doctors take the
class and I think the the rising tide
lifts all boats
and so that's what I try to do with with
that workshop is try to point people in
the right direction of how to write
better if you're interested in that
listening at home it's how to write
better org it's October 22nd and it's
the last class I'm gonna do for a while
just because I have to say no to
something so I can say yes to the things
that we're gonna say that yes to next
year and all these creations speaking of
creations Ryan and I are in the middle
of building a a film and podcast studio
and that is why we're moving to Los
Angeles we were and we're doing that
with the help from you all because we
don't take any advertisements and we're
asking that you help us support this
support this podcast we have about a
million people who download each episode
and if we could at one point get to just
1% of those people who are willing to
help us out we could create something
meaningful none of the money zero
dollars goes to me zero dollars goes to
Ryan a hundred percent of it goes to
building this podcast in film studio so
we can try to spread this message in
various ways so we're talking video
essays mini documentaries interviews
vlogs improved audio quality we want to
take callers live on the air with the
podcast we want to do a bunch of cool
stuff but we need your help with that if
you're interested just go to the
minimalists com click on the donate
button at the top you can contribute one
time via PayPal or on patreon and you
get access to all the live streams and
private podcasts and all that stuff
that's going on over there you know who
else I want to thank tonight we had some
American Sign Language folks over here
and I didn't get a chance to meet them
so I'm going to give him a hug really
quick
I almost got up during your talk to do
that
she's hiding the other one is hiding
you can't escape we owe you one hug we
give out hand hugs too in case you're
you know paranoid about the whole hug
thing I'm just really grateful that we
have an opportunity to contribute to and
and we couldn't contribute a sign
language obviously we would make fools
of ourselves so thank you for being here
tonight and I want to thank the man
behind the minimalism as well we have a
podcast producer he's also our road
manager our tour manager our operations
manager he is our book editor our
podcast editor he responds to emails and
he's an all-around outstanding guy
ladies and gentleman podcast Jean is
hiding somewhere in the shadows could
not do without you Joan
[Music]
we have been a hundreds of tour stops
and I can tell you that the staff at
this theater is top-notch I mean
unbelievable thank you so much thank you
thank you I mean seriously
Algonquin krama Commons theater I mean
this is we showed up what we got here
for like late and there was traffic
coming up from Toronto and they just
walked us right through they had
everything on point you don't get that
most of the the heavy-metal venues that
we are usually at but we're really
grateful for that and I also want to
think one other person and that person
is you I know you spent some money to
get in here tonight and we really
appreciate that but you spent your two
most precious resources as well you
decide to spend your time and attention
with us this evening and if you leave
here with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for your
time thank you Ottawa
[Applause]
hi my name is Courtney and I'm from
Houston I just recently started
listening to your podcast and they're
really bringing a lot of value to my
life and helping me realize how much of
a consumer I am I actually just got done
listening your consumerism podcast and
one tip that I had was I found rocksbox
it a subscription that kind of lets you
rent jewelry so it still satisfies my
consumer need where I want to purchase
the new and hit fashion but I wear the
jewelry for as long as I want and then I
send it back for someone else to use and
get value out of and it's only like ten
dollars a month so there's other
subscriptions out there similar that I
found are kind of awesome that you can
rent your clothing in jewelry through hi
Josh and Ryan my name is Doug Dolphin in
Cambridge Wisconsin and I have a comment
about the collar Jesse from the budget
podcast and so here it is Jesse said
that his you know he kind of raised a
question like maybe his parking tickets
got out of hand and I just you know want
to say that I really think they did get
out of hand especially if he was calling
into a podcast for help with them so you
know a little bit of real-life I think
jesse has to face up to that and just
one caveat before I go any further so
the town I live in it's a pretty small
town in the Midwest in Wisconsin and
maybe Jesse's calling from a larger city
like Chicago or San Francisco where I
hear you know parking is kind of a game
and really requires a lot of time and
effort to accomplish so maybe we're
coming at this angle from two different
perspectives but I think I have some
useful advice for Jesse so I'm going to
offer it so if
you have issues with paying parking
tickets I think there is a fundamental
issue with you know your life because
the opposite you know not getting a
parking tickets when you go to park your
car all it requires is basic reading
comprehension and obeying signs and so
if you know it sounds to me that that's
the real issue here you have in trouble
you know keeping an eye out and being on
top of things in order to not get
parking tickets and so if this is the
problem I think Jesse you know when he
goes out driving and he's going to park
his car he to really work on increasing
his awareness of his surroundings you
know in order to see the parking signs
and obey them and you know this could
also require him to set up reminders you
know maybe on a calendar that when he
does go out he asked to think about this
issue because obviously it's something
that is negatively impacting his life so
he has to heighten his awareness and
prioritize not getting parking tickets
hey guys this is Nick from Evansville
Indiana I just wanted to give you guys a
shout out and really thank you for what
you've done
I just really got introduced to you guys
here recently and in implementing some
of the things that you guys have talked
about I was able to get rid of old
furniture and old knickknacks and DVDs
and things that were just filling up my
house and in getting rid of all those
items I was able to accumulate around
$1,000 in selling it on Craigslist and
Facebook marketplace and with that money
I was able to fund that the road trip
that I'm now on I'm on day five of this
of this road trip going all over the US
and that wouldn't be possible if I
hadn't implemented this system that you
guys helped me to do so I just want to
thank you guys so much for for that and
tell you guys that I'm loving the the
minimalism lifestyle and thanks again
guys
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine
without your team
[Music]
you
[Music]